in the last video I told you that if you
had a quadratic equation of the form a x
squared plus BX plus C is equal to zero
you could use the quadratic formula to
find the solutions to this equation and
the quadratic formula was X the
solutions would be equal to negative b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac all of that over 2a
and we learn how to use it you literally
just substitute the numbers a for a B
for B C for C and then it gives you two
answers because you have a plus or a
minus right there what I want to do with
this video is actually prove it to you
prove that using essentially completing
the square I can get from that to that
right over there so the first thing I
want to do so that I can start
completing the square from this point
right here is let me rewrite the
equation right here so we have a X we do
a different color I have a x squared
plus BX plus C is equal to zero
so first thing I want to do is divide
everything by a so I just have a one out
here as a coefficient so you divide
everything by a you get x squared plus B
over a X plus C over a is equal to zero
over a which is still just zero now we
want to let me get the C over a term
onto the right hand side so let's
subtract C over a from both sides and we
get x squared plus B over a X plus well
I'll just leave a blank there because
this is gone now we've subtracted it
from both sides is equal to negative C
over a and I left a space there so that
we can complete the square and you saw
in the completing the square video you
literally just take half of this
coefficient right here and you square it
so what is B over a divided by two or
what is one-half times B over a well
that is just
B over 2a and of course we are going to
square it you take half of this and you
squared that's what we do in completing
the square so we can turn this into the
perfect square into a perfect square of
a binomial now of course we cannot just
add the B over 2 8 squared to the left
hand side we have to add it to both
sides so you have a plus B over 2a
squared there as well now what happens
well this over here this expression
right over here this is the exact same
thing as X plus B over 2a squared and if
you don't believe me I'm going to
multiply it out that X plus B over 2a
squared is X plus B over 2a times X plus
B over 2a x times X is x squared x times
B over 2a is plus B over 2a X give B
over 2a times X which is another B over
2a X and then you have B over 2a times B
over 2a that is plus B over 2a squared
that and this are the same thing because
these two middle terms B over 2a plus B
over 2a
that's the same thing as 2 B over 2a X
which is the same thing as B over ax so
this simplifies to x squared plus B over
ax plus B over 2a squared which is
exactly what we have written right there
that was the whole point of adding this
term to both sides so it becomes a
perfect square so the left-hand side
simplifies to this the right-hand side
the right-hand side maybe not quite as
simple maybe we'll leave it the way it
is right now actually let's simplify it
a little bit so the right-hand side we
can rewrite it this is going to be equal
to if we well this is going to be B
squared I'll write that
term first this is B let me do it in
green so we can follow along so that
term right there can be written as B
squared over 4a squared and with this
term what would that become this would
become in order to have 4a squared as
the denominator we have to multiply the
numerator and the denominator by 4a so
this term right here will become minus 4
a c over 4a squared and you can verify
for yourself that that is the same thing
as that I just multiplied the numerator
and the denominator by 4a
in fact the 4 is canceled out and then
this a cancels out and you just have a C
over a so these this and that are
equivalent I just switched which I write
first and you might already be seeing
the beginnings of the quadratic formula
here so this I can rewrite this I can
rewrite the right hand side right here I
can rewrite as b squared minus 4ac all
of that over 4a squared this is looking
very close to notice b squared minus 4ac
it's already appearing that we don't
have a square root yet but we haven't
taken the square root of both sides of
this equation so let's do that so if you
take the square root of both sides the
left-hand side will just become X plus
let me scroll down a little bit X plus B
over 2a
is going to be equal to the plus or
minus square root of this thing it's
going to be + the square root of this is
the square root of the numerator over
the square root of the denominator so
it's going to be the plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac over
the square root of 4a squared now what
is the square root of 4a squared it is
to a right to a squared is 4a squared I
start 2a squared is 4a squared or the
square root of this is that right here
so to go from here to here I just took
the square root of both sides of this
equation now this is looking very close
to the quad right we have a b squared
minus 4ac over 2
eh now we just essentially have to
subtract this B over 2a from both sides
of the equation and we're done
so let's do that so if you subtract the
B over 2a from both sides of this
equation what you get you get X is equal
to negative B over 2a plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac over
2a common denominator so this is equal
to negative B let me do this enough in a
new color
let's do it in so it's an orange
negative B plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac all of that over
2a and we are done by completing the
square with just general
coefficients in front of our a B and C
we were able to derive the quadratic
formula just like that hopefully you
found that as entertaining as I did